today i got roped into helping my dad  with boy stuff and i'm gonna bring you  guys along to tell you what i learned  apparently i cannot put these gas cans  in the car with my honda civic my dad  said to fill them i have to take his  truck and i have no idea why okay my  dad's going with me to the gas station  because he says he doesn't trust me i'm  offended and hurt offended and hurt  okay okay  so apparently this is how you strap a  gas cannon i thought i could just seat  buckle it into my honda civic but i  stand corrected  final product so i found out it's  because gas is dangerous and it can  spill in your car  and burn stuff  and make it smell